When I was Professor Charles Spence an experimental psychologist. I work in Oxford University.
And there on cross modal research laboratory. Have been for the last seventeen years or so a lab that brings together.
Psychologists food scientists chefs composers fashion designers marketeers are all brought together to look at their
how the senses interact and apply the latest insights from brain science to the real world. So how do you know your.
Work or cross model Research Laboratory as a name for the lab
or research laboratory I guess you get across my little bit is a cross between
and modal all the senses that's caught between the senses and how I want to sense can affect another sense.
So if I add a certain fragrance it make make people look more attractive if I change the sound of the crunch it may
change the feel of the crisp visual examples of cross sensory across modal research.
And I want to call these so-called you know your senses what you call this field.
Various names for the sorts of the so rare but there could be a multi sensory perception
and multi sensory integration multisensory research. Is kind of a common term. Always what you're doing. Was my thing.
I guess since undergraduate here back in nineteen eighty something I had to do a project for my undergraduate degree
and didn't really have any idea and earth things that interested me at the time
but somebody put me on to this guy who had a broken T.V.
and For my first project my first experiments were about sort of a breaking televisions
and moving the sounds so I didn't come from the T.V.
They came from somewhere else and just seeing how that impacted people's ability to perceive what was being said
and where they thought things were happening. I don't know that the yeah.
So you can imagine a little apartment or flat bed in the south side of Oxford and you have a T.V.
and Some people come around to watch a movie that could create start rolling and years automatic music.
Everything seems fine and then once the critics of finished and the first actor starts to speak.
Suddenly there's a disconnect because you see their lips moving on the screen
but the horse is coming from the loudspeaker over there.
Your brain says what's going on my senses are coordinated there's like a moment of sort of stopping
and trying to figure out what is going on.
But then a few minutes later suddenly your brain puts it all back together again.
And you start to hear the voices as if they're coming from the lips on the screen that we have a ventriloquist dummy
illusion
and Michael research was looking at that sort of situation how it is that your brain to tax discrepancy between where
it sees things and hears things that high puts it all back together again.
And that is a multisensory perception of multi-sensory integration as I take a voice that I hear over here which I
think belongs in the voice of the lips I see on the screen over there. And your brain can I can use them back together.
And that is the topic of my study and over the years I started on hearing and vision back in the late eighty's
and over the years I brought in the sense of touch and then mood
and everything we can think about doing in the sense of touch. Then come smell that comes taste and pain and so on so.
Adding senses to the portfolio as the years go by so fast and hard to say depends who you ask if you are.
Ask the people in the lab as I do. The reverse. I just ask questions they don't have answers but at least five.
I could find I could reference to people who say as many as forty three.
So that's kind of the problem of definition of what is a sense certainly hearing vision touch taste
and smell what everyone agrees on touch taste smell hearing and vision.
One of the five basic senses that I think everyone agrees are five senses.
Beyond that you might think about the sense of a kind of your body in space and how it's moving.
You might think about kind of pheromone all sense of the chemical communication between creatures of the same species
we know exists in animals maybe exists and humans maybe not.
And from there you'll find others who will talk about pain is that a separate sense. Or is it part of touch.
Some you might even claim as and a magnetic sense or.
Or a sixth sense a feeling of there someone's looking at me or I know what's going on
and the list goes on some I want to say. Something that.
Not in the way it's used in and marketing
and so I work with car companies that are sold like cars having her sixth sense.
About what people normally mean by that is just kind of an increased awareness.
Almost like a spooky awareness of I think it is quite high. You know that you know that someone is looking at you say.
So I think we are can be pick up things and be aware of things without realizing how we know
and sometimes information comes in not through the sense we imagine create magine we can see most of the stuff we know
about whereas in fact maybe it's that it's a subtle smiles that can tell you whether somebody else has just come back
from the pub always been watching a scary movie whether of you later on something else.
These are kind of subtle cues that sometimes get dominated by the higher senses of vision
and yet can nevertheless feed into our judgments
and sometimes because that feeling of knowing at least translates as everybody.
What do you think is the most important. More important.
I think definitely is a kind of sensory hierarchy some senses are more important than others.
Most of the research most of the writing.
Most of our introspection tells us that vision is the dominant sense the most important one and certainly
when you look inside the brain.
You'll find more of the cortical real estate is given over to processing what we see down to any
or all of the other senses.
So the numbers from the neuroscientists would be something like fifty to fifty five more than half of your brain is
involved in processing visual inputs from your eyes just ten fifteen percent of your brain is involved in hearing
or in touch and eye comes to smell or taste.
You're down to one or two percent in terms of our shop or aim is given every chance it's clear that vision dominates
and yet most of our research last twenty years has been trying to demonstrate how important the other senses are too
and that depending on the sub sorts of questions you ask all the situations you're in in fact what we smell what we
hear what we feel
and even what we taste can be far more important than we realize not just making the dominant sense
but it means more information has more value to be had to stimulating the other senses.
Even though we don't think about it very often we don't talk about them so much and they are of a visual. Yeah.
So OK yes. So. And we we. It's possible to use more of our senses. Or is it. Both. So.
Why not just stay with the visual well as a number of answers to why engaging their senses is interesting
and ultimately important from a research trajectory so personally then there's a lot of open space to be tackled.
There are many many very clever people who just study vision who just study hearing.
But having so many look at have a sense is connect being that kind of jack of all trades knowing a little bit about
each of the senses opens up a huge kind of Harry research space.
And that's really exploded over the last quarter of a century. So important in that way but more generally.
So I think if you go back to when I arrived in Oxford in the eighty's there were.
There was a scientist who just next to him was a scientist who just started hearing.
And they haven't spoken to each other for you know decades literally that some falling out.
And neither thought that they lost anything by not speaking to it or I can just focus on them for my whole life.
That's all I need to know about what that guy over there does is irrelevant to me it's a different sense.
So I think was
or was coming up we've seen since sort of the seventy's as people start to get interested in how the senses interact
normally hearing and vision it's the easiest to study the most commonly studied these the higher the rational senses.
Then as the years go by people start to bring in touch as a spatial sense tells us where things are.
I know only then do you find the only of the last in this century. Do you find people looking at smell and taste.
Why because they are maybe sort of harder to study your subjects adapt they get full up it's messy.
I can't just put in front of a computer.
You know where you go mixing smells and tastes and flavors and food that's much more challenging
and requires a broader skill.
That and for that reason it has been sort of neglected and until very recently but I see it
and are on a mission to try and convince my colleagues that are the lower senses so-called the smell
and taste on the touch are much more important or exciting to have a profound impact on our lives.
My colleagues have met maybe just smile at me and maybe say now that I would stop hearing and vision
but I have to Mystic that as years go by more and more researchers will start to engage with the other senses
and that will be the front here that we're sort of at the moment
and I see some of them starting to do research on taste in a way that they've never done before.
And I see a huge kind of public interest in. Everyone likes to eat and drink. You know you think it's a folder.
That's right. And I want to time to that we. So. I think if you go back in a way.
So there's a few three trends kind of kind of coalescing at the same time.
On the wall and you sort of find I think about what two thousand
or so you'll find people saying a sensory overload is just too much information to me screens too many mobile devices
beeping in and flashing to me videos of that's all just too much information I can't really capers
and stressful just being anywhere but
when you break that down what you find is it's mostly just from hearing vision is too much technology allows you to
present more and more audiovisual stuff.
But it doesn't do anything for your sense of touch is doing things your sense of smell or taste
and it's that kind of realisation it's kind of sensory imbalance almost that we're overloading these higher rational
senses at the neglect. At the cost of our more emotional senses.
And there are some benefits each sense probably is good at delivering certain kinds of benefits or awards or
or things making it much easier to deliver those through through touch and smell
and maybe seas of society at large moving toward sort of aroma therapy mass arge spa treatments is going to be a growth
area and maybe it's partly about bringing back the touch and the smell in a way it was being missed
or lost from society at large I think also partly about the growth of the star chef and everyone loves.
Most people love to watch cookery shows the ready kept on the television on without seeing some cookery show
or other that's been a huge explosion of interest.
And those chefs have over the last decade a number of them engage more with the senses
and there was a gate with the senses but they're on T.V.
and I thinking more how to not just engage the senses on the plate or in the glass
but in the environments in which they serve their diners. I'm trying to figure out the sort of science behind it.
They do into it if it artistically or science here to help support the sorts of design decisions they're making
and then you have the rise of a kind of a millennial Zz who are from what all the marketeers will tell as they don't
want products and things they want experiences experiences that they can share.
And those experiences can be delivered through smell and taste and other kinds of sensory Soria.
Sensory experiences multisensory events. Now I understand. That might die. But. So. If you give it a name and.
Like as we are you probably knew. I certainly hope so that the kind of research we do and the people we talk to.
Well I've become in some of them to think more carefully about how their own sense for worlds
and how the senses are engaged in a day to day basis. I think we're seeing a bit of a shift also in a way.
From what we've had sort of decades of what's called the Experience Economy companies brands from from Starbucks to
Lego to Disney.
They're not selling your product anymore they're selling you experiences
and that's been a hugely powerful driver in marketing and you can't open a magazine
or go into any shopping centers without somebody telling you I'm going to give you the experience.
That experiences of a car in the city multisensory of his last few decades felt like it sort of companies who eat who
are delivering the experience of living the senses. To us manipulate you to make you buy more.
What's I think changing now and what I see a lot happening in the U.K. Especially in London is kind of the rise of.
Of what some are calling kind of sense blur ration.
I mean it's kind of it's almost like the public you and I taking control back sort of curious about our senses
and wanting to experience more experience differently
and this explains the rise of everything from your classical music concerts you listen to while tasting matching wines
perf human concerts chocolate with the way that contemporary jazz
or the Tate Museum in London last year had the tapes and sorrier for paintings from the collection that.
Two
or three thousand people got to to view while at the same time feeling some virtual touch smelling some perf human maybe
even eating a chocolate. It's connecting the senses in.
New way
and he sort of feels like it's going the artists of the colony artists experienced designers chefs who are who are
exploring the space and almost given the chance to to make new connections between our senses.
Is that you know exploration rather than exploitation I guess that kind of shift I think
and it's a shift that's also built on going from kind of obvious sensory interactions which I mean things like you go
to the Rainforest Cafe in London and it's like a rain forest so you look at the greenery.
And you get a thunderstorm and some rain and maybe a smell of the green notes or it's going to obvious in a way.
Yeah I got it. Or you know it.
It is in a lot of the top restaurants are trying to picnics in there
and picnics that have the smell the sounds of the picnic of nature and the basket.
Yeah it's a works and gives you all the senses it's kind of obvious
and what's more interesting is the more kind of synesthetic. Kind of connections aren't so obvious.
So for example that most of us will connect us with roundness.
With pinky red color with high pitch or sweet taste with around.
And most people say bitter tasting foods dark chocolate coffee is angular that's going to surprising almost sense that
a connection between our senses hadn't realized yet.
And you can ask your friends and they all say the same
and they're also these surprising almost synesthetic connections between tastes
and smells colors shapes textures feelings as we pick up on those new connections
and we're in this environment where consumers want to explore the senses and we have the artists
and the chefs who want to play
and deliver new stuff to consumers things that really were so rich Next us for this whole new way of engaging because
it is it's almost sense that a connection. That's why all of us need to try to. Elf.
To see if it might to my brain work like that too.
Or is it just jaws and what are strange connections might be there and where were the fun and the size stars.
So it's all the same. Yeah. Where does Sirius that is. Really are so serious. Yeah and I just wonder.
I mean for the perception of people. For people to do. To join this idea.
Just so far you can just get people and there's nothing there's no difference or you can research
and make your own theories. About. Which model.
Doesn't really influence the way we live and how we are in a serious way because. So so far.
If I think sweetness is about.
What you know of what you might do if you are a chocolate manufacturer for example
and you're being told by government
or out of the goodness of your own heart you think you want to reduce some of the unhealthy ingredients in the foods
you present to the market. If I could tell you that. By making your chocolates rounder.
They will taste sweeter to people. So you can reduce the sugar content but keep the perception the same.
That something people might want to know about and certainly do if I can tell you from any other food
or drink product that by changing the shape of your product out the logo on the label design.
You can set expectations in the mind of those you're serving bacon and hands that taste perception.
To that brand loyalty that can maybe help you to just to reduce these unhealthy ingredients by his tricks of the mind
but it's something that you know pretty much every large food and beverage come. Is interested in.
They know that if they actually reduce sugar of the actually reduce salt
and fat consumers will say just stop it you're spoiling my favorite brand put back the way it was now well being told
by government we have to do this and we need a good thing for society at large. Maybe.
So these kind of tricks of the mind by changing the color by changing the shape by eating while listening to some sort
of music that can bring out sweetness.
Potentially at least offers a way of keeping everyone happy making your foods healthier.
Without changing the taste for the consumer.
But of course in the first instance the company will go puff ridiculous what you mean I'm not much of that round going
taste sweeter. If you go. Up to eleven leave it surprising. So we go through. Yeah.
So we do experiment experiment experiment publish them in scientific journals
but no one ever reads those which is where then the interface with the chefs
or experienced designers comes in if we can do large events where we have thousands of people coming through
and they get to experience for themselves that when I play this music.
What you're tasting taste sweet on a play that music suddenly taste more bitter than that's was where kind of
convincing people
and from that really is fun enjoyable engaging multisensory that sense permission from that that's the kind of STARTING
POINT. To take the science that we do.
Which means boring
and dry put it in the hands of creative chefs for mixologists storks beers designed to turn science
and something fun exciting enjoyable and tasty and then expose people to it
and through that is a proof of principle that then the big brands the lions the hospital trusts come they experience it
and they never of that do it by themselves.
But they experience at a restaurant or in these events and then they go away and innovate and Reza case in point.
Just take British Airways. Yeah line.
There it's a long haul flights from eighteen months ago we were doing tastings with music for some of the.
They came along they got it and then they went back and changed the music in the long haul flight so that
when you order a meal in the airplane.
You can plug into the headset in the side of your seat
and I saw one music channel specially designed to enhance the taste of the food that they're serving so by music.
For everybody. You. Also if you can change every every perception or every experience of one of your senses.
Or what happens to your your feeling of truth because I know I like drug use.
Well your idea of juggling the way and it says you like mine. So you also.
I mean I guess what is true that we all psychologists food critic why next.
But regular consumer like believe we can for example just taste the drink in the glass of the food on the plate
and all of us believe that the chair you're sitting on the lighting that the music has an impact.
Now didn't feel that way it feels like I'm tasting what's in the glass and you can't convince me otherwise.
There are many chefs and the people we talk to who are of that opinion and intuitive glass of sherry myself
and yet I know when we do the research and we measure how I give you a squeeze of chocolate and I say how sweet.
Was it from one but it was very better to ten which is the sweetest chocolate you've ever had. I know that.
I can guarantee that every single person eight out of ten say or eight hundred
or one thousand will agree that this chocolate.
We're going to sweeter taste sweeter to them
when the sweet music's playing the most as we will deny that music is having an impact that also that
when I tell have schools.
Those My sweet music those who are busy music now see the difference and that is the proven I think in a way.
I can't you can't turn water into wine. There are limits. So these are mostly kind of notches.
If I give you food that's a bittersweet like dark chocolate or a black coffee with a sugar.
I can make it ten percent sweeter.
Or ten percent more bitter but I can give you a glass of water
and some have changing music by changing the lighting make you think you're tasting wine or anything else.
So there are limits to a sort of truth of your senses.
But it's always flexible there's always modifiable but it never fully never fully you know. Because it is only.
It's been said if it were if you take the example of the classic example of you get the wine expert
and you get them a glass of white wine and you add some color less total US red dye. So it looks like a red wine.
If you can convince that expert and many experts have been convinced that what they smell.
Are all the red wine aromas that chocolate or tobacco and stone fruits that feels like feeling.
Mixed with that red color make a smell citrus on straw or on honey on and battery notes are the red color
and suddenly it smells completely different to the expert.
You could call it fooling you could call it trickery
and that maybe there is no absolute truth of our senses because we always eat
and drink experience things in some environment in that environment whatever it is wherever we are the clothing to food
to cocktails to coffee. To a car sales room.
Roy getting sensory inputs and they're all really having some impact on others.
We all deny it and it's our job kind of society as a psychologist not to believe you
when you tell me this is what it is influencing your behavior.
Why you like something more than another but instead to measure and observe your behavior and your performance
and demonstrate that sometimes the way feels to us is not the way it actually is and it's to pick those examples and.
Everyday Life. I think. You're Northern European as well.
So you'd understand the problems all rose a paradox
and everyone has that experience they go on holiday to the sunshine to the Mediterranean and that glass of red here
and taste beautiful cheeses marvelous Is this the sausages are fabulous so good in fact.
And so cheap you want to buy some and bring them back home.
And you bring that wine back home and on a cold winter's night you open it with your friends to swish.
Recount tales and it tastes different.
It doesn't taste like the same wine
and everyone is at a version of that experience in Taiwan they come to England the tea tastes amazing they take it back.
It doesn't taste different in South America wife is from it's a cottage
and on the Colombian coast things taste different now than they do in the capital Bogota. And I wanted to experience.
What is it.
It's not that the wine has changed all that has changed is the mood that you're in
and the atmosphere in which you eat and drink. And.
Can you say that the way we see things and is very very broken is that you know. So let's have a question. Whoa.
Why do we need so many senses wooden just one day.
But after five or six or seven
or thirty forty three because you're more senses we've got more trouble your brain has trying to combine what it hears
what it sees with what it takes so the fewer the senses the simpler the kind of computational problem to be solved.
You might think. So there is a cost to adding more senses.
On why do we have so many and why do we have the ones that we do.
Well maybe it's something about you know I say Gee isn't dark ages meaning the vision wasn't so good so other senses
came out and developed and then the lights came back on as it were and suddenly you got two senses and
but in fact I think the real answer is that each and every one of our senses is noisy we are.
Biological sensing system. So it's always noisy noise machine. Like a computer.
And that noise in the system means that sometimes the thoughts alarms.
I think I saw something that I thought I heard my name
but no so all the time this kind of false alarms each of our senses is just noise in and sending these false alarms.
And if we only had one sense to go on would be perpetually distracted by these laws that would actually have something
happen. However if I think I hear something I think I saw something.
It's very unlikely that two of my senses accidentally fired at the same time and if I thought I saw
or heard something and they were both from the right. I think more likely so by having different senses.
But each we assume have passed separate noise variation then by kind of pulling two senses.
I get a much better index of what's happening in the world and can ignore more the noise of my sensory operators.
Since you have the better in the sense that's part of the advantage of illusion really speaking
and it also probably is the case that each of our senses is good at something
and each of our senses is good at something different.
So I want to know what something is where it is my eyes are as good as any sense if I want to know
when did something happen.
How quickly did it change my ears are much better than a mechanical rather than a chemical transduction then
when it comes to something like. Mate selection.
Who should I get married to or not really my nose tells me about the immune compatibility between me
and this other person in a way that I can't see that a cop feels or smell is useful
or smell is useful if you think about if I presented you with a plate of beautiful fish.
It looks fabulous all the trimmings. But it just smells a bit.
It is coughs then your nose would dominate and you would not eat that thing no matter how hard. Beautiful.
It looks so small then becomes dominant for avoiding poisons perhaps to make make selection and taste true.
I'm going to warn you. I'm going to get warn you.
Or provide different kind of window into the world
and so for you know what I want to know what should I eat what might poison me what will be neutral. If I me.
Give me the calories and the and the protein and the minerals this taste is really the only true sense
and picking up those qualities and yet revolution we've learned that I can't put everything into my mouth
and seal it taste like that would be too time consuming better use my eyes.
To predict which trees have the right Proops learn the.
Fruits go from green and sour to read and write and then I know by looking. Where I can get the best tasting food.
So all the senses working together and realizing that each one is dominant and good different kind of thing.
So there's a sense. To this a sense that been there has been talk or.
A magnetic sense that it was some some some birds maybe some other creatures have this
and some navigate towards North know
and you quite how it turns out that they that they have some kind of magnetic sense
and the BE A few suggestions in the end even various team scientific journals of humans to some humans have some
vestige of a. Magnetic sense.
That's one that is on the cusp where would be nice if we could all have a really fully functioning magnetic sense.
So I wouldn't need to read a map of all that stuff I could just know how to get home and leaders know that way.
Two hundred miles. Would be great. So that would be one that we could say we miss it is clearly there.
In other species and some of my colleagues in Germany have been trying to train us to have an extra sense.
So they might they be putting about on people in Germany.
So computer coding in colleagues put a belt on people and then vibrates and where it vibrates tells you where north is.
And they get you what you wear this vibrating belt for six weeks two months with the hope being that after that time.
You may have learnt almost
when to put that vibration as kind of a magnetic cue we were talking about this meeting is there's no I don't need. We.
Three.
Oh you can you can educate the senses I suspect in this case it will always remain always feel like touch
and they want to feel like and you sense I guess. So we can educate the senses to be better.
Most of the research is in the case of those who've lost the sense those who are blind or deaf.
Can they use some sort of sensory substitution system to use one of their remaining senses in order to make up for the
loss of vision say in their tactile visual vests.
There are glasses that have little sort of cameras on the side that may change what you see into what a sighted person
would see they'll change it to sound the question what sort of sound should you happen.
And those blind people who hear the world as a sighted person see do they really see.
Or do you have to have these things in order to actually see that stuff Lear very philosophical question about what
does it mean to see but I suspect mostly it's about.
You can train the senses to do more stuff better stuff but it's probably impossible to to create a new science.
Or to take what existing sense and. Turn into something else and it will always stay.
I think it was so when we look at the reasons. Now we enter a new era where what we expect or more.
Will be that will be in time. So looking forward and terms of how it will be sense multisensory stimulated.
I think the answer to that question in a minute maybe partly about desire more people would like to happen
and how they'd like their senses to be stimulated. But it's as much a matter of technology.
How can you deliver sensations differently.
And I think the last ten fifteen years a lot of our research on Touch say for example has been driven by the fact that
now you know.
Tactile technology tactile stimulation mobile devices in screens in cars where you name it is now that the technology
exists and maybe now there are three billion fiber ating devices in people's pockets. That wasn't a cased decade ago.
So suddenly the technologies allowed us to stimulate the skin in new ways that all these things didn't exist ten
fifteen years ago and they ubiquitous now. So that technology allows us to simulate a sense of touch more.
Hopefully better and the question is how what benefits can we deliver.
Is there something about mechanical digital touch that is never the same as a real.
Personal Touch or can we simulate it all and I suspect there may some of our research.
I suspect suggests the stuff we read suggests that maybe you cannot simulate.
So real touch the Midas touch the gentle casual touch.
That will make you feel better pick up some of these change return your live reports on time big get a bigger tape that
kind of casual touch is kind of emotional use of the sense of touch.
You might say could I deliver that my just touch it seems to make the world a better place by by tactile vast Well
having us. Just set up by breakers just do that. It turns out.
No it doesn't work that seems to be something special about real human to human touch the mother's touch is kind of a
name that. Was at my desk in my seventy touch turns to gold the.
Way it works in the hands of social psychologists is that if. You do a study and you just gently touch somebody.
On the shoulder be at the waitress in the restaurant the little library in the library be the person on the street then
those who are gently touched. Who have had their eyes at Midas touch in fact show more pro-social behavior.
So they will return alive Reeboks they will pay their fines they will give a bigger TEP they will be more social beings
just from this into personal touch because this is kind of personal touches so beneficial in some sense.
Those who are not developing the technology to vibrate our pockets our hands are wondering could we deliver that
through your touch screen your your your i Pad your your mobile device.
And it turns out so far no one's been able to do that. Maybe there's just something about real touch that's missing.
Maybe when when you feel the touch of another person. It's got a certain speed.
Maybe get a certain temperature and I know if I look in your and you're hairy skin.
I know exactly the speed that your skin likes to be touched. Maybe it's not copying that who knows.
So it's a technology that is in the world of touch and is doing that already. Then if you think about smell.
Where are you going to. So you say well we see evidence it. In fifty years. Or we might imagine that.
Maybe every device will have will be touch enabled in some way.
Everything from the cutlery that you hold
or you go to the restaurant to the car that you drive who are still driving to any.
Phone Smartphones tablets computers. Maybe the whole B. Touch enabled. Through the chairs we sit on.
You know you already have a massage chair so I don't like that for you because feature of any thing that they're
actually work with love or vibrating the table so touch I think will be everywhere
and it will be used to for a variety of purposes to transmit information.
So everything around this very situation will.
Or will it will give us information something or maybe any digital device will have some that we interact with.
Will have some sort of tactile functionality.
Not just the feel of the thing itself
but it will be unable to vibrate to give us a Lucian's of touch to give the perception of temperature or wetness.
For example.
So working out with clothes companies in thinking about the transition that most people are increasingly doing their
shopping online and that's fine for books and C.D.'s when it comes to clothing.
Also Marc and I want to feel both average going to be like.
Our bit less comfortable doing online coaching that there's a lot of interest in how you can.
And able kind of technology we have a home our laptops and computers.
Is there some way we can trick the brain into giving you the feeling of real materials.
And by so doing kind of in crease sales of online sales of clothing and other stuff.
So how do we virtually create touch and texture. Any kind of tribute.
I know that if I if I give you food to eat with heavier cutlery than it will taste better to you be willing to pay more
for it. And now somebody in Far East has created a digital fork. That by some sort of vibration and stimulation.
It will feel have you to you.
It's not literally have you just tricked your brain by stimulating the sense of touch in a new way to give you the
illusion of weight.
That something ought to be built into everything's we know already that if you see something like that a Bang
and Olufsen remote control here let's not let's not let's not on health issue we say there's no OK.
Everyone's going to be upset that we don't studies with certain people your books and your polls.
And just drop a little white in the bottom of the orbit and people believe we're going to be full or soon
or your brain can't separate the weight on the hand from the weight of the thing that's in the package.
Have you got really helps another technology to do that.
So I imagine any sort of advice would be thinking how do I engage more senses because this is what the sensory
marketers are saying whatever product or service.
You're Levering engage more of your consumer senses touch is an obvious one is it has been neglected for so long
and yet it's sort of our biggest sense eighteen to twenty percent of our only mass given over to the skin
and it can deliver some of the fact if I don't it benefits make us feel good if we just don't relate it right yet
but everything you say so it's all about the benefit for.
That I hear a lot of arguments that governments can benefit from because we can influence people.
But what will be there all benefit for mankind and that. I think something like. Well good position.
A lot of people are worried about their weight if I give you a simple trick to be satisfied with less food which
involves you incurring a little lead weight around and putting it in whatever probably you're going to eat.
That's only we can all use in an enabler for all clearly companies might use that for their own means and ends
but it's something we cannot live inside itself it is flexible in its usage.
And it is something anybody can apply to their daily life doesn't doesn't quite high technology does some of them some
starting to do so you say now this year twenty sixteen will be sky books published on the topic of Bowl food eating
food out of a bowl five cookbooks whole trend a wave of interest what was going on just food in a bowl.
I don't get it but think about that.
That's a lot of sensory design
and it's with a bowl the more likely to hold the bowl in your hands of you hold the bowl you feel the way to feel the
weight you're satisfied with the last
or the whole food movement is around trying to eat healthier eat less in a way can control aware of your weight
and controlling it.
And so have you have a bowl in the hand helps that it's a warm bell maybe makes the world seem better.
And that you can smell the contents more tricks to brenne different way.
So there are trends that are out there already that people are engaged in that you can reframe in terms of this sort of
sensory sensory design we didn't realize but you do realize you can measure it
and what could be done through to I'm thinking a lot about a tour in Saudi Arabia
and by the way that pediatricians talking about infant touch.
So it's good for my wife's not here moment but she was premature by about three months.
And actually popped out and so she's about this big..
To have thought about here and I think that's because as a premature infant in the one hundred sixty S.
You're stuck in an incubator and left you were touched. It turns out if your premise your baby a difficult birth.
If you're touched.
If you get this effect of touch message in his early months you will develop a healthier normal weight with less
illness as a result.
So I believe passionately early life touch is very important
and it can be lost that a lot of parents will not touch their offspring both normal weight
and the kind of pre-term ones
and yet from all the studies I see you have a profoundly beneficial effect both on bonding both on quality of sleep on
on all. Sort of health and disease prevention it all comes just to stimulating the touch.
Maybe releasing some rumors well.
And I'm going around the world trying to tell the pediatricians this is important
and you should be at educating young mothers on the benefits of a personal touch. It's been neglected.
And it's in all of our hands literally to to do something about it. However gentle.
Because it will never be it always being.
As you we were always has more than we used to so maybe it's more rebalancing
and I think this is a reality where do we also get richer experience.
I say a more different kind of different balance of sensory experience
and in particular I want to say more connection with emotional side of our being.
Of the world that is smell taste
and touch these are the emotional senses with much more direct links to sort of mood and emotion.
Than our hearing
and vision have to go over to the back of the had then come so so it puts in touch with our motion side I think that's
a good thing that's been neglected and I can point to these many examples you know from that from the infants to their.
Old age pensioners to those in hospital who. Who.
If you can engage in the emotional sciences more intelligently designed. Lead to benefits.
Wherever you look you can pretend infants.
Old people are wrinkly
and then want to touch them through you know kids in hospital who are so petrified if you could patting dog
and talking to the right.
And yet that relaxation will come through touch with another object far outweighs the other things
and does lead to improved.
Recovery
and I think across the across all the sciences you can see how being more aware of the impact of all of our senses
being more aware of the sensory imbalance we can cause ourselves into largely as real technology can lead to a better
more filled world as a result. So. Is it possible that in the future we will give more value.
Senses for all experiences. Right now. For example in court with an eye witness is possible.
So I think looking forward. Are. OK With the increased value put on the other senses. For sure.
I am also kind of conscious in a way that it's almost no matter what I do no matter what the research shows.
Nevertheless there is this kind of recurrent bias saw a belief that there will always bring it back to the visual in a
way so I see it's a work in and fashion stalls and also situation.
And where I can prove that adding the other senses makes the experience better.
And yet I'm very aware that the consumer or person at home or that company will attribute that improvement to vision.
Just take an action about the Euro football a moment.
I know if I can give you the technology exists to give you a little plug into the side of your T.V.
That were released the smell of fresh cut grass. So you can see them playing on the screen.
You know the smell of fresh cut grass.
I asked you homeless to learn the experience how to enjoy the game of football the ratings would go up.
I believe with a cent. Unable to T.V. and Yet I think after watching the game.
I could show you your results went up you liked it more but you say no I just it was just a good game.
I can see it now and it was really good football.
So always misattribute the causes of our experience to the wrong things and if. That's a challenge I think.
And it's a rare. I guess up from five or ten years ago that I used to believe.
Well if I can prove it then the world will change if I can show you the graph
and say OK look is how much Europe peoples experience went up how much sales went up.
You have to believe that you might say well is did you do your experiment well but once you believe me on that score.
If it's significant.
That's it time to change the way we're doing things
and yet through experience I realize that's just not the way things happen often.
There's a whole section of the world of people you might want to influence who no matter how no amount of evidence will
graphs or data will ever convince those to how they can ensure it is beliefs
and kind of go with that somehow so simply buying more experiments by writing more papers by showing more graphs will
not do it. How else are going to influence them.
And this is where I think for us this idea of kind of experiential events often working with chefs or
or bringing people into environments where we can change lives and changes it and demonstrate them.
That's much more powerful to many people and that does lead people to go away
and say OK I'm going to do things differently where I am going to show the graph.
I just know what I felt
and we've had people coming out to do the three thousand person wine tasting where we change the lighting change the
music use has one glass of wine in your hand a score card and see how fruity how much you like the wine
and then you do what is called Card still got your glass of wine and I change the lighting.
I change music and I ask you to taste the wine again and suddenly taste different and then change the lighting again.
And you won't taste.
I'm not doing was to one changing I'm making it more fruity fresh more like the less like some recreating the problems
all rose a moment. In one environment ten minutes.
And not everyone gets it but those who do said you know it's unbelievable.
I think it's going to work and then as soon as you change the lighting change the taste. You know.
And with that the power of your own experience. That's what will drive people to go out and say OK I'm going to do it.
I took a long time to realize that that's made it a better way of maybe the only way bit of influencing people about
things that that aren't necessarily into it is to them
or go against the kind of the visual dominance that that is the bedrock
and it is built into our brains so that this sounds like fun.
Go on and make this period which changes even if you say why there isn't the why do you use during the. Yes.
And I sort of fell instantaneously for some people but it's also fun. But now that's nowhere really makes a difference.
Where. How. You know where they're understand what really in a way that. Now you know this is leaving.
The European Union that will change the way it was raised a lot of things in Europe.
People get scary you know what will happen next. Cortlandt. People don't know. So there is a difference.
And I can imagine I would transform my eyesight.
If that changes that the world around us will will change because we got our sensors our reprogrammed
or get reprogrammed without us knowing both get reprogrammed how what will that do to the world if we have our sensors
get bigger say in reality. So one might say of the maybe I could.
I'll rephrase the question I get one who will tell you. Mario to. If we use our senses.
So I won't change my thinking maybe you might say they bricks it voters they were describing on the television last
night was a once in a lifetime of political commentators in the seventy's I've never seen anything like this
and never will again no Will our children. So I think the events of the now that magnitude.
And also the work that we do is more of nudging small little mind small change here a small change there are there are
rarely full of your sick moments of wow.
So it's more and a creation of lots of little small nudges benefits improvements
and Huntsman's that over time say OK we really got somewhere now but at any one moment there's not suddenly.
And a ha moment or a shock. And I want them to write what will change when you compare. Year two thousand the year two.
So I write a lot about the foolishness of predicting what's going to happen a few years hence.
Because someone has ever done. It's always got it wrong. So.
That in one thousand nine hundred five eighty ninety four we had people I met scientists writing that a century.
Hence So I mean one thousand nine hundred ninety four people beating pills they were eat meals that's ridiculous.
Inefficient use of a pill that will come out of a slot in the wall that can only work.
How much more productive would we be that's never happened. It's never going to happen.
Going to be eating algal cuisine. Soylent Green that's not happening.
And it goes on all the predictions about what the future will be like tonight not to be like that. So I have to say up.
I no idea where it's going but if there is one person who could give me any open door to the future.
You can open any door to the future. About this field.
If you course because you know you will know more about those answers and I do
and you will be yes I know it's a surprise for us all. That you know that's the whole idea of how you think that.
You know really. The world will go the way it goes.
And you know how you can exert some influence over trends and fashions. You can drive them or predict them I think not.
So it was I got a very faint influence on. On forces that are much greater than yourself.
In society at large and technology and the extent that it's foolish to.
Even trying to predict will have this kind of overconfidence bias and gives us all a sense of certainty.
There really isn't there have to think of this referendum for leaving you or you that our senses were dominant.
That's the extent that we are primarily audiovisual creatures.
The senses are the more rational ones that any rebalancing of our senses and ramping up of smell of taste of touch.
These are the more emotional senses. They might imagine that would lead to more emotional decision making.
You take from that what you will. Whether that would have meant would have left. Or later.
Who knows one of the other Sure. So. What is your reaction for us. Regarding your research on census which is.
I don't want to miss anything. What is for you the most important thing regarding.
The Census what is what is your your main quest or your main goal.
In studying them is that the main goal for myself and for the lab I run here at Oxford is to try and understand
and take the understanding of how the senses interact. The sometimes unpredictable ways.
Our senses combine information and use those rules in the design of a different and hopefully better world
and that those kind of insights about the science of the senses about. The sensory perception.
I think spanned everywhere from the design of warning signals to car drivers through the design of food
and beverage experiences that are more stimulating or healthier omo memorable people have different of goals
or objectives through to the environments in which we live and work.
With a lot to work on kind of the ambient fragrance and paint colors and lighting and nature
and how those things might make us healthier happier more productive.
Through all sorts of ways of health care is an area that hasn't as yet received as much research around sensory design
multisensory design and you throw a few things which we better.
Generally for people in your safety and you know that it uses a lot of you.
So something like bringing hospitality back to hospitals that would be one thing that lead to a better world.
And that all will get there through engaging the senses in a more intelligent design.
Hospital health care type situations.
I think in the delivery of sort of healthier foods that taste the same as they always did to us.
That's important to many people
and yet have less of than healthy ingredients through through through intelligent design of the multi sensory
experience through everything we know about how the mind processes flavor that's going to be HUGE through sort of
because of transport technology. A lot of benefits for driver safety for air traffic control.
Fall in financial trading situations where every kind of milliseconds counts in terms of a lot of sex in a car has a.
So it's actually now. So the present time drivers are being confronted with more and more information.
Mobile phone and internet in their cars head up displays that are telling you about every single hotel
and bar restaurant. Competing with what's going to be going on outside the window screen.
There's a lot more distractions in cars and ever before.
Unable to technology all of those distractions are now being delivered by the content providers not the car companies.
So can we have a technology for years but the car companies were never really set for fear of accident.
But now it's the mobile providers for the first time can actually provide content drivers
and they don't care about safety not in the same way as the car companies do.
Well that means that if suddenly we have a generation of drivers who are more distracted or more texting.
Or the most dangerous thing you could possibly do.
And I tell my undergraduates you know for the females in the audience the most likely way they're going to die is at
the Huns of the wheel
when their boyfriends driving by far the biggest cause of death is through this texting distraction of the wheel
and so anything we can do that have a profound influence
and I see from our research that we can deliver we can get drivers to turn their heads back to the road if they're
distracted. To brake more rapidly.
If potential collision the event is occurring through not driving a red throbbing like that.
The engineer designs
but by putting science behind your head so it turns out that your brain has special dedicated circuits just this space
behind your head. The engineer never thought of putting a warning signal there.
But if I know from I'm saying how the brain works over the brain works that the special bit of the brain only has about
this for the space that isn't used while driving. If I put something in your head rest.
You can make you turn your head that much faster than anything else.
We go there for sound comes from a sound come from just behind your head your brain treats it differently processes it
differently and takes up to the same sound comes from in front.
From the dashboard
or from the door panel same sound same loud speaker that just behind your idea is processed differently now.
And for that.
No engineer in the in the car can restore that little voice out of the brain does our present understanding that the
senses and how they process information is one of the unexpected things that comes out
and you know we've demonstrated in the lab
but also the driving simulator that you can reduce reaction times amongst drivers to extent that should lead to
significant reductions in. And accidents on the roads.
For example where people drove to get a car which you're going to prevent a thing before you bus that's your action
kind of if you don't do that car. I wouldn't really say yeah but I believe so. Breath.
There is I mean you can detect if people are sleepy so probably that exact figures
but it might turn out that sleepy dot drivers are more dangerous as a group than drunk drivers
and maybe a third of all accidents are and some are related to sleepiness for example we'll tartness.
And say that is in fact a big cause of death on our roads.
I now radio the car companies can detect signs of falling asleep.
You're calm ask your question and then depending on how you are response you can tell from the gaps.
You can measure your blinking. You can measure how tightly your You're squeezing the steering wheel.
You can measure how aggressively you're braking and trim
or those cues can get a pretty good an estimate of your sleepiness. So I imagine the same is true for.
Four four I'll call low. There with. The sleepiness one definitely.
So the I know that the car companies have been working on the technologies to predict the sleepiness of drivers.
And then take countermeasures which probably if your car switches itself off you think you're tired now is going to buy
that car. But if it be automatically lowers the windows or releases an alerting scent.
That's not quite such an aggressive move.
Ideally should stop but maybe that's kind of into media companies are thinking in that space
and have the technology to work. In terms of the drinking while driving. I haven't heard actually anything.
In that space and your example of an angel were going to say well maybe they work.
That's a strange jump from from from car drivers to financial markets
but it was in a way they're the same in that this research on the design of warning signals.
Is an area where every millisecond every thousandth of a second matters. There are many other situations in life.
I mean I say I can save you one hundred a second.
So what who cares what I do to life driving and financial markets
or two of the few areas where such tiny improvements influence can lead to huge financial consequences be it in health
care provision for death at the wheel or gears and profits made in turbulent financial markets like for the last day
or two.
So they need something like the figures from Information Week one of the magazines for every millisecond advantage.
A typical sized trading house gets in the spin which information comes in that's one hundred million dollars a year to
that company. So you're already see that the. Lot of these companies will put their offices as close to.
Well the cables come out from under the North Atlantic to get that little millisecond advantage as compared to the
competitors who are in the city. So they're physically doing things to maximize speed up.
But they've never as far as I can tell ever thought about the design of that interface screens the alerts that they get.
So you know it has just happened.
You need some sort of special sound that maybe that would give you a few milliseconds advantage.
And if you if you're an economist then you can you say well. To the global economy.
What would the benefit of one millisecond faster braking be in terms of accidents
and more the latter you can say to the financial markets what would the benefit of one millisecond be to a lot of money
made by companies that they can actually equate say maybe they're worth as much or maybe the financial markets.
That's a bigger.
Potential market for milliseconds mattering and I mean because financial
and result there's a lot of my work is is taking domains that are very different the so you can apply the insights here
and there's thirty years of research on warning signals for car drivers and as far as I can tell there's nothing.
On trading one traders. Nothing. That's always the so much knowledge here and does it's the same thing.
But we have different different plans and that's a lot of our research is just taking insights from one area
and saying hey can we apply them over there who are tied to a particular industry or product or category.
And in fact there's lots of knowledge that just is sort of siloed. And what about. When.
You say well if you are able to read people by using your sense. So there is no suppose about it as a fact you can.
Help reduce modulator pain through the senses. And there are a number of ways. Doing it has been proven to effectively.
What you're what your partner.
So we've done a very small part of the research looking at how we can take insights about how the sensor interaction
from one domain to another. So for example from every move learned about sensory dominance in food.
How can we apply that to our sensory dollars
and pain relief from pleasure pain such as twenty of the same continuum maybe what we've been doing is for example.
We know that you perceive things more intensely if you concentrate on them. And if you're distracted.
You don't notice them as much. So a lot of pain relief strategies say for bandage changes very painful procedure.
What can you do to distract people take their attention away somewhere else it will hurt less.
So it doesn't work on attentional manipulation.
So maybe if you watch a very engaging video visual distraction painters less that's a factor.
That's going to incorporate it in some areas
but we've also been looking at his patients here in Oxford working with an Australian colleague we're looking at a
special group of chronic Regional Pain Syndrome say R.P.S. Patients and these are rare.
Fortunately very severe cases of birth people who've been on the motorbike or thrown off in a car accident.
Broke something seems to recovered. And then six months later.
Suddenly they get it's excruciating pain that will not go away that medication has no impact on the surgery seems to
have no impact on where you're left with a lifelong chronic pain and all them.
So we've been doing work with these patients who are very hard to work with if they're in such pain they don't are
taking part in when your experiment is the last thing.
I think they want to do
but those who've been able to work with you know show that if I can make your hand look smaller I can use visual
dominance. So we have Asians looking at that.
That affected limb through a pair of binoculars or been turned backwards so they look smaller
and if you look at your limit look smaller to you. Really. And it also reduces swelling.
So this psychological trip of just using visual dollars of the eyes has by the psychological impact on reduced pain
but also a physiological impact on reduced swelling in the limb. How long this lasts.
I can't say I demonstrated we do it in an hour for twenty or fifty or one hundred of these patients.
If you catch your limb and it was very small for a week a month a year. Who knows how long the effects will last.
Will they wear off. It's possible we don't know.
But it's going to very difficult very long term at least in the short term we can deliver pain relief through these
sort of tricks of the mind so lower my colleagues who are thinking about. Fragrance I know that for babies.
When they have some ask what's called a heel preposterous procedure very painful.
What the nurses do they give the baby a sugar cube.
So sweet taste reduces and they get across Mobile In fact my colleagues in Australia.
Have been working in adults to see whether a sweet smell can do the same thing.
So if I ask you is strawberries caramel has been allowed a sweet.
You say Yes I smell sweet because literally smells weeks once a taste and smell the smell
and yet you can smell sweet and if you diffuse that aroma while people are in pain they will rate the pain lower
and they'll be able to resist for longer
and they get using the senses using sight in one case using smell in another and I'm equally convinced in.
The effect of sound. You know you go to the dentist.
I'm sure if I could take that sound out to be a wholly different experience.
I could quieten it if I could play the sound of chipping birds something else. It just would last.
So all the senses play a role. So what are the things. Around you. That must be solvable or. You may get. Your ears.
Which you saw here
and you know these all you maybe something so it's up to sort of there are there are lots of questions that someone
like myself can answer as a lot of unsolvable things that I'm not the right kind of specialist for.
Those fortune I think we have insights that could be useful then almost any situation of daily life is the potential
benefits of better sensory design
and that is you know from hospitals to health care to offices to the home to the workplace to the airplane.
To the car to transport wherever you look I think engaging the senses all of the senses better would lead to more
immersive more engaging healthier more enjoyable more memorable experiences. So which the ones we haven't got yet.
They tend to be the ones where it's going to be hard to do hard to get to.
Our hard to convince those in authority that this is something they might think about.
So all of those hospitals is one that I think so.
Huge potential market loss and insights that we take from designing supermarkets
and stalls to be better a lot of the insights and you can apply to the health care situation. We haven't got there yet.
Because all of our grant applications been turned down.
Finally we've got a Spanish hospital just outside Barcelona that treat a private hospital that treats children with
cancer and they were very open minded approach to engaging with a sense and I did some brilliant things
and we have start working with them since this year together with the colony center to design sensory design not
sensory design of health care for some very sick children.
There are also things I think we can apply there some are thinking in five
or ten years that will come to be much more relevant.
Airplanes is another one of the mentioned some of the sound bite this music that will have the taste of the food
but I think there's a lot more that can be done there.
It's just hard to get access to do the experiments on the airplanes. But I see some of the some of the big line.
You know they want to innovate to differentiate themselves at least at the top end in the first and business class
and yet you think I am the more celebrity chefs can they get them to realize that celebrities have doesn't make the
food taste better. That's not the way to go.
So you got you've got the intention but not the execution and I think engaging all the senses
and think about the whole experience of the problems all ros And how do you put that into the airplane might offer
the potential to radically innovate in that space to. There's money there's interest but they are together.
And the trading floor. Is another one that's.
Has its own peculiar difficulties in that the financial traders are masters of the universe. They think their god.
And their every every hour of that time is worth.
How many million euros
or pounds whatever it is so I want to test them I want to take part in the experiment so I can demonstrate to them the
benefit of using this tool that. That important to give up their time to take part in research.
Does the other person reason is it is quite impossible to get to maybe know what.
There are ways around it but there are also some challenging mames.
Because of the use in control of them or because of the practical limitations. I hope you will get there somehow.
So the challenge really for us is to say how do we how do we influence though that those who are controlled to take
that step. So we know very well we don't.
So I guess there's a potential that if we don't use we don't use it you lose it is kind of the phrase that gets bandied
around a lot
and one might think of something like our pheromone all senses kind of into concepts of ik chemical communication that
we know dogs have another animals have but humans seem to more or less have lost sight we didn't need it.
And maybe that is our suggestion is that when we went from four legs
and our noses very close to the ground the smell was very important
and then we went up into two legs suddenly we're much further away from the smelly stuff.
And hence that's partly whence our sense of smell started its decline.
And that now if we compare ourselves to dogs and clearly dogs are much better able to navigate
and to tell apart things through smell. Whereas our sense of smell.
We can see in the evolutionary record that it was very important.
It's more of a genetic material it's given over to smell than to any other sense. And yet today.
Look at U R I N R R R R nasal operator says is sadly diminished. From what it once was in the past so losing it.
You could say you know there are problems. If you would like to read the extinction of the species isn't it.
Is it a problem that little furry rats somewhere
and I mean they're off to five hours of New Zealand just could extinguished.
They also be a problem there are cuts after. Much. If we lost our senses.
I mean there's a question you can ask people if I have had to take one of your senses away which one would you least
like to lose and never goes of course my my eyes.
But in fact if you look at suicides after the loss of a sense that people are far more likely to commit suicide after
the loss of smell than vision.
This is the one that gives you your emotional life your connection your enjoyment of food.
Linked to sort of attraction and so does that this is the one that actually leads to you should avoid a lot of.
That maybe those who are blind
and still have that still have the memories of images they can create for a number of years after.
Taste it turns out is probably the least important one.
You could get rid of that maybe you would not realize
and I have been a few scientists in history who lost their tongues to syphilis
and the French army were quite fond of chopping out.
Algerian tongues and Napoleonic wars or whatever it was and in both cases it seems. Nothing much changes.
So actually taste your time might be very important.
All I know is if I were in danger of losing them I guess it'll be a very slow decline. And I think really probably.
We still do use all of our senses some of the time.
So it's not that we never use smell like if you don't rank awful smelling fish you will use it then you will use it for
detecting fire.
So they all are still used and we're trying to just increase the amount of time that people are
and connect in touch with or thinking about all mindful of their other senses. But.
What I was really really depends which one we lose big with this role for emergency room. So we do. That.
We have lost it depends which scientist you listen to when you mostly lost it.
Then when I whether we have lost it really no I actually I look at dogs and say I can see that they get all horny when.
This sort of smell comes along but I don't feel like I'm missing anything by.
Now in that sense I guess people by the very fact that you say which sense would you least like to lose
and nobody really says smell implies that we don't evaluate as much as perhaps we should.
Loss of the sense of touch is pretty pretty debilitating.
So he's going to tell you which we should we don't know if you know this. Like it or.
Don't we need every parent not let me get on OK. There is. So. So you know maybe. What happens is.
Maybe we evolve with different individual senses telling us about different part of the world all of our stuff we need
to know about poisons and pleasures food. And mates.
And then our brain with all this information starts to combine the senses and we have multi sensory perception
and then that allows you to almost sort of predict or do things differently.
In a way so I guess we humans are quite rare in not only tasting food also smelling it as
when we swallow act it is pushed into the back of our nose.
So it seems like we have a pretty unique way of tasting food that involves a nose.
As well as a mouth and not many other species all of the species have that.
So it kind of adapted or learn new ways of doing things through combining sensors and.
What ways or using sense was developed for one thing for something else and that maybe now without.
If I look at the the animal kingdom that maybe makes selection is mostly about smell
and pheromones doesn't really matter. You know how shiny that.
And the talk or something else or hot it's all about smell. And humans it seems.
Otherwise it's a pre-primary about the visual. So maybe we change our dominance.
When I would visually driven creatures. Maybe men more and more than women who were doing things a different way.
Maybe we'll do something that maybe I'm not as able by visually inspecting a potential mate to figure out whether
they'll make a good sort of genetic match in terms of the immune response of the offspring smell would tell that much
more directly seven to smell. I still might become eight and reproduction will still take place.
That maybe there was some errors or problems that will will ensue you use your depth as a research.
Because words are visually dominant so love is so is the thing again of we.
We miss attributes or we will develop this bigger visual brain Talbot's to find fruit in the trees
and then once half of our brain is given over to vision. It's hard not to use it for the other things.
So if we go on dating. Yeah it's better to do that. So that's the thing that I think we better genes all your senses.
The more sense.
You have the more information you've got and essentially about sight different stuff
and yet we have been working with artists like Clara city who have been doing some playing in this space thinking about
the smell dating agency. So she and others are our famous for getting a hundred people to wear a T.
Shirt don't wash for a day or two and bring your teacher. And then that the speed data is just smile all the T.
Shirts from one to one hundred. It's all I'd like to take that one and that one and that one.
And then you get to meet the one and sometimes it's somebody about a sex that you're not a very small one
but it's actually a man or vice versa and a bit of a shock and other times and they smell great but they look awful.
So when you do I guess you'll end up reverting to your eyes
and yet I still wonder if you were given both not just the kind of the online visual profile
but also the smile with those two cues. Maybe come to a better choice. And it is going to get worse. What works.
Where you are you three will smell the most smell different your teachers will smell different
and they'll be more attractive to some people than others. So there is information there.
We don't all smell or same and somebody will have attraction to one does it work.
What would be a long term consequence if we had you know did the experiment one hundred people you can only pick your
mate from a picture
and another hundred you can only pick from Smell who would wish which group with the divorce rates be higher.
That's going to experiment that.
Probably will get their fix to do better and so you won't you know I'm not sure actually.
I definitely think that if you have the smell and the vision you do better than just a vision.
If you had one or the other cures that are these that have ethics you see
and then they would let me hear there is an artistic expression expects perience. Art Project you can do it.
But if your measurement scientists then go to the Ethics
and then people start wondering about the ethics of that sort of.
But it is interesting and it is sort of open it's more. To make you think differently and maybe there are some.
Differences between males and females so about. Feelings. Using your senses.
Is possible when you reprogram your senses or your senses a different way.
That you experience of feelings like love or heal or jealousy or anger.
I don't know where you want to put feelings and emotions that they're not exclusively tied to a particular sense.
So I think I could show you a range of faces
and you say that one looks happy that one looks sad that one looks guilty that
when I was depressed I could I could play you some of the sounds of people's voices you could do the same thing I could
even put your hand out.
And I can pretty tap and stroke and you were able to be able to decode the emotion through touch
and even through smell you can someday react and smell happy from fearful.
So the same things are so if the sense is it possible is it possible that you have an army.
You will find you have already let you use there but your smell. Anything else to build up a feeling of hate.
For example. Is a possible. Does it does it does it's no different here in Britain.
Don't want to be part of yeah but today better.
So it's certainly true that the ambience that can change our mood make it more relaxed more aggressive.
Make us more alert or more relaxed. They might say I want my fighting force to be. Sort of alerts not relaxed.
So maybe you're thinking a certain kind of. Citrus open it's really better than lavender or camel mile.
And beyond that. For example if a police. Just played. You go you. Know. Is it possible that you will go. Yes. Really.
So if possible so we say. Maybe so there are studies out there.
That you can change the scent in the slot machines and Last Vegas
and there are certain sense of make people spend more.
People's ears away tell you what the scent is exactly but they say it works a special sound.
If you believe that there are all sorts of act comes you could get their sense all
and increase the likelihood of a negotiation coming to a successful conclusion there a sense that could be worked on
the trainer trading floor to say. Even so frame it as is there a sense that will get people to spend more.
Is there a sense that will get people to be more aggressive Is there a site that will make people fight better or
or can fast sooner. You might get I think you could get any of those outcomes through scent.
They're really going the mechanism is well if you're more lax.
I can tell you all sorts of stuff where it's not time intensive I want
and the mechanism that smile makes you confess sooner is by making you react perhaps. There.
The reason why sent makes you spend more is not directed at you spend more.
Maybe more comfortable next time passed slower. But when you relax times passes more slowly.
And there's a sense of the sense that. For some stuff on to negotiations conflict. Solution.
What sort of space should they.
Yeah fighting parties be in there's a painkiller matter you asked as a lighting matter you asked of the chair you
sitting on that I guess are certain phrases that might work better than others but undoubtedly.
So what you're saying is that it will make you use them right. Yeah. Mostly from the U.S. Military.
Is very strange that you get an email from colonels
and so please send me some stuff can you give us quite conference to our.
You do that and then the next week say our first time something is on the paper
and send them a matter of control by which time the e-mail accounts go black doesn't exist. Never existed.
Two or three times so they do get in touch if it's a real name or not and we pass on some information.
I think is useful. Little of interest in the maintenance of surveillance.
If I'm trying to detect a potential terrorist threat or aggressive incident when I've got my cameras.
We've got more C.C.T.V. Than anybody else but if i also the microphone and I could to sense.
With that could be more information and if so what. How would I combine.
The sound from the microphone with the scanning image. So there is interest there and try to sort of build.
What we've evolved naturally this multi-sensory perception and you build it in engineer it into robots
and surveillance systems and other types of equipment
and stuff through to work on alerting people if you know if I can make a car driver hit the brakes half a second faster
and you make a soldier shoot somebody.
Almost as much better as well through a long term kind of a pop up for long term performance. In the field of.
I want to tell my operative what to do but if I say Oh. Hank. Should be left then the oppositional here.
So maybe if I have a vibrating suit I can. I can communicate without sound without vision.
So the other senses are left open.
That's of interest
and we've been working on vibrating body devices through for those who don't like very long term missions say if you're
on a or those intercontinental refueling or long distance bombing routes.
How do you keep your pilot awake for long enough.
Nice to talk pills and stuff but now there's work
and if I if I capture the blue light of dawn that can trick brain into things dual time to wake up
and Swedish truck drivers through military pilots can be kept more alert for longer thought of playing with the sensors
in that way. So a lot of potential.
And I guess we've done bits
and pieces with the Dutch kind of military research partly military research that you don't see as examples where for
simulations.
It is important whether it was the soldiers simulating what's going to light when they're fighting somewhere new.
Or if it's for the doctors simulating what can be like operating in a military hospital in a war zone.
It's forty degrees in a tent with dust in your eye then just showing people a virtual reality doesn't do it where it is.
Really I guess you call it. Maybe it's all meant to reality. So it's something that's a blend of both.
Distinguish like the difference between zero and one so might be say
when it's all sort of virtual It's all constructed without any technologies what can the information is coming from
your eyes and your ears and your nose. There's no direct readout of what's out there in the world.
It's always going to hypothesis generation your brain predicting imagining.
What the world is like and then occasionally testing reality against your model.
So the way we're always living in a virtual world doesn't feel like that.
Wait that's kind of how the brain said look if everybody. There is actually to some degree grounded in.
Physical stuff but all related to physical memory.
I'm in part of that will to learn how the world is through prior exposure and and pick up
and regularity of the world
and then use those to predict how the other one is going to be like in a few moments time we check.
And that descriptive.
Says a word on one of the question What Well is it isn't all up section kind of virtual or is it all an illusion.
Through to how Will technology is virtual reality oriented reality become the new norm
and replace Who needs real nature when I can stick you in now with a headset
and play the sounds of nature in the smells of nature is as good as the real thing.